Kvantové počítače vstoupily do éry užitečnosti
což znamená, že je můžeme začít používat k řešení
reálných problémů, včetně těch, které jsou velmi obtížné
pro klasické počítače
běžným tématem současné éry
je, že se nějaký problém vyřeší
poprvé na kvantovém počítači
a pak lidé postupně najdou způsob, jak to udělat na klasickém
počítači – tento cyklus, kdy se klasické
a kvantové počítání navzájem tlačí na
své hranice, bude pravděpodobně pokračovat
ještě několik let – existují třídy problémů, kde kvantové
počítání může mít prokazatelnou výhodu
oproti klasickému počítání
vzhledem k pokroku v oblastech, jako je
snižování chyb a počet dostupných qubitů
existují také celé oblasti aplikací
kde by kvantové počítání
mohlo být užitečné v relativně blízké době
jednou z těchto oblastí je kvantové strojové učení neboli QML
kvantové strojové učení označuje
využití kvantového počítání pro jakýkoli typ strojového
učení – existuje samozřejmě
mnoho typů strojového učení
dva zvláště zajímavé typy jsou
supervised learning, při němž
trénuješ algoritmus na popsané datové sadě
a unsupervised learning, při němž
algoritmus pracuje z nepopsaných vzorků
a snaží se naučit něco o rozložení
nebo funkci, která ho generuje
unsupervised algoritmus může
například naučit se generovat nové vzorky
ze stejného rozložení nebo jak
seskupit vzorky do skupin s podobnými vlastnostmi
supervised i unsupervised learning často zahrnují
vkládání dat do vícerozměrných prostorů
a manipulace s daty ve vícerozměrných prostorech
by nás měla přivést na myšlenku kvantového počítání
dovolte mi vysvětlit – představ si, že řešíš problém, zda
klasifikovat datový bod z roviny
jako kroužek nebo křížek na základě popsaných trénovacích dat
někdy lze data jasně oddělit přímkou
nebo rovinou v nízkých dimenzích
jak je vidět zde, a klasifikace těchto datových bodů podle
těch nad přímkou
a pod přímkou by měla být
snadná – ale podívej se na toto rozložení
jasně není viditelná žádná přímka, která by oddělovala datové body
nicméně pro tato data si dokážeme představit nějaké
zobrazení ze dvou dimenzí do tří dimenzí
takové, že po aplikaci zobrazení naše data vypadají
takto a existuje jasná rovina, která odděluje obě
třídy, kterou můžeme použít
ke klasifikaci – pokud se ti toto pojetí zdá trochu zjednodušující
máš pravdu – nemůžeme jen tak posunout datové body, které chceme
výš, bez jakéhokoli zdůvodnění
musí existovat zobrazení
ze dvourozměrného rozložení, které efektivně odděluje
naše datové body, abychom mohli
použít zobrazení ke klasifikaci nových datových bodů
tohle bude podrobněji probráno v lekci o přehledu
strojového učení, ale stačí říct
že problém lze vnímat jako
zkoušení mnoha různých zobrazení do tohoto vícerozměrného
prostoru, abychom viděli, která zobrazení poskytují nejlepší
oddělení datových bodů různých tříd
tato manipulace s daty ve vyšších dimenzích
je jednou z oblastí, kde kvantové počítání
může mít velký dopad – abychom pochopili proč
vraťme se k rozdílům mezi klasickým
a kvantovým počítáním – stejně
jako klasické počítače používají bity informací
kvantové počítače používají qubity
ale pro daný počet bitů, řekněme čtyři
klasický počítač může nabýt libovolného z
dvě na čtvrtou, tedy šestnácti možných stavů
kvantový počítač má také přístup k šestnácti možným stavům
ale může existovat v superpozici všech
šestnácti stavů současně
a operace mohou být prováděny nad celou touto superpozicí
pro čtyři qubity to možná nevypadá
jako velký problém, ale představ si, co by šlo udělat s
kvantovým počítačem s dvě na dvacet nebo
dvě na sto dvacet sedm
stavy najednou – existuje mnoho dalších rozdílů
mezi klasickým a kvantovým počítáním, které
všechny hrají roli v tomto předmětu
kvantové stavy mají komplexní amplitudy pravděpodobnosti
manipulace s kvantovými systémy se provádějí pomocí
unitárních operátorů a kvantové počítače jsou vystaveny jiným
druhům šumu než klasické počítače
tyto rozdíly se budou objevovat
v celé tvé práci s kvantovým strojovým učením v oblastech
jako je kódování dat, feature mapping a mitigace chyb
v některých případech tyto rozdíly mezi klasickými
a kvantovými počítači nám umožňují navrhnout zcela
nové algoritmy – tak to byl velmi stručný přehled
propojení dvou nesmírně složitých oborů
ale doufejme, že jsou jasné dvě věci
strojové učení často řeší problémy
manipulací s daty ve velmi vysokých dimenzích
a za druhé, kvantové počítače jsou dobře vybaveny
k manipulaci s daty ve vysokých dimenzích
a dělají to jinak než klasické systémy
to by ti mělo dát pocit
proč je strojové učení slibnou oblastí
pro uplatnění užitečného kvantového počítání